♪ ♪
>> Jesse: THE OLYMPIC PODIUM
BEING USED TO PROTEST AMERICAN
SHOT PUT SAUNDERS AFTER CROSSING
HER ARMS ABOVE HER HEAD DURING
THE MEDAL CEREMONY THIS WEEKEND.
SHE SAYS IT IS TO REPRESENT A
OPPRESSED PEOPLE AND TELLING THE
INTERNATIONAL OLYMPIC COMMITTEE
TO TRY TO TAKE IT, THE METAL.
THIS COMES AS OLYMPIC THEM OR
THROWER GLENN BERRY TURNED ON
THE AMERICAN FLAG DURING THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM IF YOU LOOK AT
TRIALS AND SAYS SHE WILL DO IT
AGAIN IF SHE REACHES THE PODIUM
SAYING "I FEEL LIKE I'VE EARNED
THE RIGHT TO WEAR THIS UNIFORM.
I WILL REPRESENT THE OPPRESSED
PEOPLE.
THAT HAS BEEN MY MESSAGE FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE THAT HATE ME,
THEY ARE NOT HERE SO THEY CAN'T
AFFECT ME."
ALL RIGHT, KATIE, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
COME AND TAKE IT.
>> Katie: WELL, WE WILL SEE IF
THE INVESTIGATION PLAYS OUT AND
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMITTEE ON
WHAT YOU ARE ALLOWED TO DO
PROTESTING.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT PROUD OF THE
COUNTRY THEY ARE REPRESENTING.
I THINK WE SHOULD FOCUS ON THOSE
MAKING OUR COUNTRY PROUD LIKE
THE MEN'S RELAY TEAM AND A
GOLDEN SWIMMING, THAT WAS
AMAZING AND I LOVE WATCHING
THAT.
TO EMPHASIZE THE POINT, OUR USA
ATHLETES CAN GET UP THERE IN
PROTEST AND COME BACK TO A
COUNTRY WHERE THEY HAVE FREEDOM
AND THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH TO
SPEAK OUT AGAINST THINGS THEY
THINK ARE UNJUST.
IN THE MEANTIME, THERE IS A
POLARIS RUNNER, HER NAME IS --
HER LAST NAME STARTS WITH T COME
I WILL NOT TRY TO SAY IT.
>> Jesse: JUST TRY TO SAY IT.
>> Katie: SHE SPOKE OUT
AGAINST THE OFFICIALS AND
CRITICIZE THEM.
HER LIFE IS IN DANGER AND SHE'S
TRYING -- HE THINKS THAT SHE
WILL BE KILLED.
>> Jesse: WELL MET, SUCH A
JERK.
>> Katie: ANYWAY, THE POINT IS
IF YOU ARE AN AMERICAN ATHLETE
YOU CAN PROTEST AND COME BACK TO
YOUR COUNTRY AND LIVE FREELY AS
IF YOU ARE FROM ANOTHER OF OTHER
COUNTRIES AND THE MAJORITY
AROUND THE WORLD HAVE NO RIGHT
TO DO SO OR TO DO THAT WHEN THEY
GO HOME.
>> Jesse: TOMATO OR TOMATO.
>> Richard: I ACTUALLY AGREE
WITH YOU TODAY, KATIE, ON THAT
POINT.
AND MAKES MY LIFE EASY, BELARUS.
BUT I THINK THAT IS GREAT THAT
YOU CAN GO TO THE OLYMPICS, WIN
A GOLD MEDAL, CIVIL MEDAL,
BRONZE AND EXPRESS YOUR
DISAGREEMENT WITH A COUNTRY PIER
THAT IS WHAT MAKES AMERICA
GREAT.
THIS IS NOTHING NEW.
WITH ALL THIS AND THAT MIGHT AND
68 GAMES TOMMY SMITH AND JOHN
CARLOS THE UNITED STATES AND
MEXICO CITY.
WE HAVE SEEN MUHAMMAD ALI DID
THE SAME THING.
LISTEN, POLITICS AND ATHLETICS
HAVE BEEN CONNECTED TO, EVEN
RICHARD NIXON WITH TENNIS IN
CHINA.
THIS IS NOTHING NEW AND I'M
HAPPY TO SEE THESE PLAYERS ARE
EXPRESSING THEMSELVES.
>> Jesse: I ACTUALLY DON'T
MIND THIS AS MUCH AS SOME OF ANY
THING REALLY DROVE ME NUTS BUT
THIS IS NOT THE BEST, NOT THE
WORST SPIRITS BEFORE THEY WERE
AMAZING THINGS, INCLUDING THAT
GUY WHO WAS TRIPPED BY THAT GUY
ON OUR TEAM, USA AND TRIPPED BY
THE GUY AT BOTSWANA, AND HE WAS
ON TRACK TO WIN.
INSTEAD OF GETTING MAD, GETS UP,
SHAKES HIS HAND, AND THEY RUN
TOGETHER.
>> Jesse: THAT'S NOT MY
REACTION.
>> Dana: NO, THAT WOULD NOT BE
YOUR REACTION.
BUT HERE IS THE THING, FIRST OF
ALL, QUINN PERRY WANTS TO
PROTEST MY FIRST, YOU HAVE TO
WIN.
>> Jesse: YEAH, RIGHT?
>> Dana: YOU MIGHT GET A
MEDAL, BUT WHEN YOU ARE...
THIS IS THE THING ABOUT IT, IF
YOU ARE GOING TO DO THIS, YOU
CAN'T PREVIEW IT.
IT LOSES ALL OF ITS IMPACT.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
>> Dana: FIRST OF ALL, WE
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WILL WIN A
MEDAL.
SECOND OF ALL, HERE SHE GOES.
LISTEN, IF YOU DECIDE TO DO
THIS, THAT IS YOUR RIGHT AND YOU
THINK THAT IS YOUR RIGHT, YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE
HAS A RIGHT TO AN OPINION ABOUT
THAT ACTUALLY IS WELL.
SO THEN DON'T GET MAD IF YOU GET
A REACTION.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE A LOT OF
STRONG OPINIONS.
>> Greg: FIRST OF ALL, I GO
BACK TO THE ACTIVIST FOR AN
OLYMPICS, ACTIVISTS WITH FIXED
PHYSICAL FITNESS.
I ALWAYS WORRY ABOUT THAT, THEY
ARE OUT OF SHAPE, OVERWEIGHT,
AND MISERABLE.
IF WE COULD GET THEM INTO
REPEATED PHYSICAL FITNESS OR
PERHAPS SOMETHING LIKE -- IT'S
NOT LIKE THE ACTIVIST OLYMPICS
AND JUST LET THEM -- I THINK IT
WOULD BE BEAUTIFUL.
YOUR POINT IS, WE HAVE THE
ATHLETES WITH POLITICAL POINTS.
THIS IS A POLITICAL SHOW.
I SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE
COMMENTS ABOUT ATHLETES.
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE VERY GOOD ATHLETES.
>> Richard: THEY HAVE TO WIN
THE GOLD OR SILVER MEDAL.
>> THAT'S MY OPINION.
AND PEOPLE LIKE TO WATCH THE
OLYMPICS BECAUSE THEY LIKE TO
ROOT FOR SOMEBODY, YOUR TEAM,
TEAM AMERICA.
IT'S NOT A PERSONAL, ATHLETIC
ENDEAVOR BUT YOU ARE
REPRESENTING YOUR COUNTRY SO
IT'S NOT LIKE THE NBA, NFL WHERE
YOU CAN LIVE IN L.A. AND BE A
FAN OF THE NEXT NEXT, WHATEVER.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
SUPPORT THEM COME UP THEY COME
OFF AS UNTHANKFUL BRATS.
SEE, IN MY OPINION, THE ATHLETES
COME A LOT OF THEM ARE
UNGRATEFUL BRATS.
ARE AMERICANS ROOTING AGAINST
THE AMERICAN FEMALE SOCCER TEAM?
I KNOW A FEW WHO ARE.
AND IT IS BECAUSE THEY COME OFF
AS SUPER SMART.
AND THE OLYMPICS ARE GRADED FOR
NATIONAL PRIDE -- EVERY DAY YOU
WANT TO KNOW HOW MANY METALS.
>> Jesse: CHINA.
>> Greg: I SHOULD SAY BEING
WOKE, NUMBER ONE, JESSE, DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU COME FROM A RACIST
COUNTRY.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE.
AND THE IDEA OF WINNING DOESN'T
MATTER.
THE NUMBER OF METALS DOESN'T
I THINK THE ATHLETES ARE UNIQUE
SPECIMENS AND THAT NO LONGER
MATTERS EITHER BECAUSE THEY
PUNCTURE EVERY ONE OF THESE
ASPIRATIONAL VALUES THEIR
BEHAVIOR.
SO IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER TO
ME.
YOU'RE NOT REALLY THAT GOOD.
YOU'RE BORING.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
I USED TO CARE.
I ACTUALLY USED TO PUT FORTH
COMPRESSION BECAUSE YOU WERE A
PART OF THE AMERICAN TEAM BUT
NOW I DON'T GIVE A DAMN.
>> Jesse: WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MEXICO AND
THE UNITED STATES?
>> Greg: COULD POINT.
>> Jesse: IT DOESN'T EVEN
EXIST ANYMORE.
>> Richard: AND SANDERS, SHE
WAS AFTER THE CHINESE ANTHEM AND
THE MEDALS POINTED HANDED OUT.
SHE WAITED.
>> Richard: JOSIE COME ON
SATURDAY, 1-2-3 IN THE MEN'S
100.
>> Greg: I LOVE JAMAICA.
>> Richard: I'M A PROUD MAK